[موسيقى
] الشعور بالانجراف هو مجرد
شيء لا يوصف لأكون صادقًا ،
إنه يشبه الخروج من هذا العالم
عندما أكون خلف مقود سيارتي
أشعر بالسعادة ،
أشعر
بالحماس الشديد لما أفعله ،
اسمي علي سيجواني
وأنا  فقط أحب
الانجراف في الصحراء ، أعني أن تعال
ليس هذا مثل أفضل شيء في
العالم ، لديك مساحة فارغة ، لقد حصلت على
الطريق ، حيث حصلت على السيارة ، لا يوجد أحد
آخر يزعجك ، أنت وحدك
تفعل ذلك  كل ما تريد القيام به ،
يمكنك ممارسة كل البدايات المجنونة ،
كل الأشياء التي تحلم
بها كيف دخلت في الانجراف بشكل جيد ، لقد
بدأت بشكل أساسي مع
الاستمتاع بالسيارات بشكل عام وأي
شيء ميكانيكي ، كيف
تكون القلعة ،
الشيء المفضل لدي في دبي هو  ستكون
الثقافة ، البيئة التي نحن
فيها نرحب بالجميع ، إنها بيئة ودية للغاية
وجاهزة دائمًا لمساعدة
مشهد الانجراف
مع الجميع في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، وجميع
الحفلات المنظمة ، وهي تنمو بشكل خاص جدًا.
خلال السنوات القليلة الماضية ،
أصبح من الجنون
الانجراف أثناء العمل على السيارات ، أي شيء
يتعلق بمحركات الدراجات ،
مهما كان الأمر ، سيكون جزءًا من
حياتي كلها ولن يستمر ذلك أبدًا
[موسيقى]